-Our first guest tonight was
the 2018 Democratic nomine
for governor of Georgia
and is the founder of the voting
rights organization Fair Fight
Please welcome back to the sho
our friend Stacey Abrams.
How are you, Stacey?
-I am doing quite well,
thank you very much.
-I'm worried about your
wellbeing because, obviously
this seems like an endless
presidential campaign
in which you are in Georgi
working very hard
for voter turnout, which
obviously is very successful
But then in Georgia, of course
it started up again
with these two run-offs.
How are your energy levels
right now?
-I am so looking forward t
January 6th and taking a nap
but until we get there,
there's no sleep till Brooklyn
We're on it.
-A lot of people have credited
you with the voter turnout
that helped flip Georgia.
And on Monday,
you actually got to preside over
the electoral college
and basically giving out
those votes.
What was that like?
-It was thrilling.
It was fantastic.
It was a little sweeter when
I learned that there was
that alternate reality elector
cabal happening right below us
and it felt good.
It felt really good in a small
petty, and yet really patriotic,
"happy for our nation" way
-I think it's very possibl
to be on the largest part
patriotic and then allowin
yourself some small pettiness,
as well.
I think we're only human.
You appeared at a drive-in rally
this week
with President Elect Joe Biden
as well as Reverend Warnoc
and John Ossoff.
How was that?
How was the sort of drive-in
rally treating you?
-It was good.
Look, in COVID reality,
the honks,
they stand in very
sub-adequately
for clapping and applause.
And there was occasionally
this stray honk that you hop
was a punctuation
of something smart you sai
and not somebody accidentall
leaning their elbow
on the steering wheel.
But we saw a lot of enthusiasm
for John Ossoff,
Raphael Warnock, and of course
the surge of applause
when President Elect Joe Biden
came on stage.
People are ready for 2021.
We're ready for him to hav
a good team in the Senate
that's willing to work with hi
and get things done.
And we saw that happen
yesterday,
and we believe we're gonna
get it done in January.
-It was obviously a big wi
in Georgia,
but it was also
a very close win.
There have been
multiple recounts.
How do you build on the momentum
of what you accomplished
in 2020?
-Sadly, people know
what's at stake
because our current senators
are arguing
over baseball names instea
of fighting Mitch McConnel
to ensure that we get
COVID relief packages.
They are making money and profit
off of trades
instead of saving
the small businesses
that are shutting down.
And we have crossed
the threshold
of more than 10,000 people
who've perished in Georgia
from COVID-19, and they ar
still planning to eliminat
access to health care.
We don't need anyone else
on the ballot
except for the two of them
to keep the energy up
because Georgians understand
that the only way to make
what we've tried to do in 2020
work is to make certain
that Joe Biden has
a balanced Senate
with two US senators
from Georgia who are willing
to work with him
to get good done.
-It does seem like Donald
Trump's reaction to the election
has put senators Loeffler an
Perdue in a tricky situation
They're both supporting
the president's
many legal claims about
the outcome of the election,
but they also have to get voters
to believe
in the electoral system
and turn out for them
in this runoff.
Has it been interesting
watching them
sort of do the acrobatics
this requires?
-It's not just the acrobatics,
it's the appropriation
of Donald Trump's ability
to lie without unity,
to distract from their
inability to actually deliver,
and, yes, they argue
that people should vote in a
system that they don't trust
and that they should do it now
but not because
it's actually going to work.
We have a very simple message.
We want to save America.
Please vote.
And that has worked,
I think, very well.
We sent people to GASenate.com
to help when Georgia.com,
we're getting thousand of people
who want to help.
And more importantly,
here in Georgia, we're seein
extraordinary turnout.
We've had two days of record
turnout for early voting,
and we expect a third
on Wednesday.
-There's been no shortage
of surreal moments
in this election cycle,
but one that's been added
to the list is
at a recent debate
with John Ossoff
and Senator Perdue.
Senator Perdue
decided not to show up.
And then in a real passive
aggressive move that I applaud
They still had a podium for him.
How do you think the podium did?
-I think the podium acquitte
itself very well.
It had about the same amount t
say about the future of Georgi
as the candidate himself
would have.
David has made a career
out of not showing up.
He has not held a single
public town hall
in six years
in the state of Georgia.
In fact, you have to contribut
to his campaign
in order to get an audienc
with him.
If you are an average Joe,
I'm not sure how your supposed
to meet with him.
to reflect on his successes.
And we need John Ossoff pu
in his place,
because you saw an animated an
present possible US Senator.
-We've talked about this befor
on the show.
You never were a believer
in the messaging
that it was really important
to flip Donald Trump voters.
You believed
it is far more important
to focus on non-voters
and infrequent voters.
What is it that you think
that President Elect Biden
has to do over the course
of these next four years,
even in the course
of the next two years
until the midterms, to bring out
more of that voting block?
-I think the first thing, an
I mean this very sincerely -
showing that he's concerne
about everyone.
I am clearly a Democrat.
I believe in the values
espoused by my party.
But I trust what he says,
and I adhere to what he says
which is that he may have been
elected as a Democrat,
but he intends to be
the president of everyone.
And when you have
a US president who returns u
to those norms where he doesn'
speak in terms of base
and siphoning off
certain communities
as being enemies of our people
but instead talks about
how we together
can defeat COVID,
how we, together, can recove
our economy,
how we, together,
can pursue racial justice.
That kind of language brings
people in.
They may be reluctant,
they may suspicious,
but at least they'll believe
that they have a place,
and they're willing to hav
the conversation.
-The president has attacke
both your Republican secretary
of state.
He's attacked Governor Kemp,
who you lost your race to
in 2018,
and one of the things
that I think is really scary
now is the reaction to this is
that we will see more blocks
putting in place
to have people vote.
Are you worried that,
ultimately,
the Republican Party,
it seems that when you liste
to Kemp and
the secretary of state,
it seems like they're saying
"Look, we're gonna put in
more safeguards," and of course,
when you talk about
the safeguards
they're talking about,
it seems like it will lead
to less Georgians
being able to vote.
-They're going to restore,
if they have their way,
they're going to try to restor
in Georgia
and around the country
in Pennsylvania, in Wisconsin,
in Michigan,
every place where we were able
to mitigate voter suppression.
When you hear the word
"safeguard,"
what you should hear is
"We're gonna stop those people
from voting again."
What we accomplished in 2020
across the country
through Fair Fight's work
and the work of so many others
including Marc Elias
and the leadership conferenc
and the NAACP legal defens
fund, the NAACP itself,
the lawyers committee,
it was a collective effort
to create access
to the right to vote.
The problem for the Republican
is that when people vote,
when they have the right t
vote, Republicans start to lose.
Newt Gingrich said it himsel
about Georgia.
If people can actually mail in
their ballots and return them,
Republicans can't win.
Their fear is not that there i
an assault on our elections,
their fear is that people ar
actually participating
and making smart choices.
I don't think any party should
be guaranteed a victory,
but every American should be
able to vote if your eligible,
and that's what they're afraid
of, and starting in January,
here in Georgia led
by Governor Kemp
and Brad Raffensperger,
but across the country,
there will be marked
and naked attempts
to pull back the right to vote
because when they control
the power,
they control it best
by silencing the people.
-I think now is an important
time for all of us to work
really hard, but also
to provide some self-care.
We talked in the past.
You enjoy to read a book,
you enjoy to write a good book
You enjoy television.
Are there any shows right no
that Stacey Abrams is watching
that you want to give
a shout-out to?
-So, love "The Queen's Gambit.
That was fantastic.
And I have been saving up
my episodes
of "Star Trek: Discovery."
That's what I get to do
over Christmas break,
the, I think 28 hours my team is
gonna give me to rest
over the holiday, that's wha
I'm gonna be binge watching,
getting it done.
And, of course,
watching every episode
of "The Seth Meyers Show"
that I've missed
during this campaign.
-Thank you very much.
I was fishing for that, an
I'm glad I got you on the line
It is always a delight
to see you.
Best of luck, and hopefull
next time in person.
Look forward to it.
Have a wonderful holiday.